انا اكاديمي وانا على وشك من الانتهاء من
كتاب جديد عن تاريخ المملكه تاريخ السياسي
والثقافي في المملكه فلذلك يعني اتردد
دائما
للمملكه لمقابله شخصيات مختلفه
واصدقاء بالاضافه الى زياره المكتبات
دائره الملك عبد العزيز مثلا وبعد المكتب
الوطنيه وبعد المكتبات في الجامعيه فلا
تردداتي كلها يعني في مجال البحث العلمي
البحث الاكاديمي كتاب جديد عن ايش عن
السعوديه من اي ناحيه دكتور
عن السعوديه نعم نعم عن تاريخ السعوديه
السياسي والثقافي والاجتماعي من
اجتياح العراقي للكويت يعني من تقريبا
1990 الى الان الى اليوم وشو يميزوا عن
كتاب
رؤى حول التغيير الاجتماعي والسياسي
والاقتصادي للمملكه العربيه السعوديه في
مرحله انتقاليه في نفس الاطار ولا في جديد
يعني
اغلب اغلب الكتب اغلب الكتب التي كتبت عن
المملكه عن تاريخ المملكه في يعني في
العقود هذه الاخيره كانت اكثرها يعني
اهتماماتها اما
موضوع الاسلام السياسي والاسلاميين او
الحركات الاسلاميه والصحوه او يعني بحوث
لها علاقه بالاقتصاد والنفط فانا انا
كتابي مختلف يعني
ما هو عن لا عن الاسلاميه اكيد الموضوع
موضوع الصحوه داخل داخل في الكتاب بس يعني
انا رؤيتي
للتاريخ المملكه اوسع
[موسيقى]
اول شيء يعني انا عندي حب للبلد وهوس في
البلد وتاريخ البلد لانه بلد يعني مثير
جدا من ناحيه العلميه والثقافيه وبعدين
اضافه الى ذلك لما لم تعطى السعوديه حقها
في الدراسات الاكاديميه والدراسات العلميه
يعني اغلب الكتب التي كتبت عن الشرق
الاوسط اغلبها اما عن مصر او عن سوريا او
عن لبنان
والعراق مؤخرا بسبب بسبب الاجتياح
الامريكي للعراق فالمملكه يعني في بعض
الكتب بس يعني مكتبه المكتبه عن تاريخ
المملكه صغيره جدا يعني مقارنه بالدول
الاخرى في الشرق الاوسط البعض يتهمك بانه
انت منحاز للسعوديه دكتور في كتاباتك
وانت جزء من حمله تسويق مقصوده للسعوديه
خاصه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وكذلك في الدول الغربيه بشكل عام شو رايك
فيها الكلام دكتور
لا انا يعني انا اولا اكاديمي
واحاول بكتاباتي انه يكون موضوعي يعني في
طرحي فعندي انتقادات لبعد السياسات في بعد
سياسه المملكه وعندي بعد
يعني طرح
بيمدح بعد السياسات كذلك يعني في المملكه
انا يعني انا لست منحازه يعني اولا لا لي
علاقه
بالدوله السعوديه الماليه او او بالدوله
الامريكيه حتى يعني ما عندي انا اكاديمي
بموضوعيه بس ما بخفي عنك اني بحب البلد
وعندي اصدقاء في البلد
واتمنى يعني الخير للمملكه مثل ما اتمنى
الخير يعني للمنطقه كلها وبالاضافه الى
ذلك انا امريكي يعني جنسيتي امريكيه
ومصالح امريكيه مهمه بالنسبه لي وارى انه
الاستقرار والازدهار في العالم العربي
بصبي بمصلحه امريكا